the unity brings all three boxes
together in perfect scene
the power builds until it can't be
contained
but if I can cause a delay between each
box even for a nanosecond its energy
will Cascade form a loop and feed on
each other and that's it we just pull
them apart no fuss no muss separating
the boxes is still going to cause a
massive surge I'll have to be there
but you guys should think about getting
clear we're with you till it's done
honestly I think we're all going to be
dead way before that
you know what
I don't mind it's an honorable end
but we gotta shut Steppenwolf down
Superman's a no-show you got no powers
no offense this guy might be working for
the enemy we don't know you're tripping
over your feet and mine
appears and strong and I know we went to
war with the Amazons but that was before
my time hey you know what I don't want
to die I'm young there's [ __ ] that I
want to do
I just feel like I never really embraced
to see or the land
alone in my whole life being part of
some
bigger like this
maybe I'm scared because
I'm meant to
come
I think that was beautiful
you say a word about this you'll meet
every prone I know
I honestly didn't hear anything after
we're all gonna die